welcome to this video this is about
round two of the open that have played
them on my account
look my hope and I hope I'm pronouncing
this this is hard way correctly yeah
this is round two and round two was
played on the same day as round one so
the first two rounds been kind of this
notorious double round way to play two
games a day okay unfortunately and only
these first two rounds had this the set
up so all other rounds were just one day
one game that's fine if you play
constantly two games a day at seven it's
really a bit much but okay the second
round was just played a couple of hours
after the the first round and only had
very brief time to prepare of course my
opponent was a young Spanish player
Javier Nicolas sapota not to be confused
with his sister was a bit stronger even
he's rated 2140 so I'm happy favorite in
the game but still he's much better than
the first round opponent
um yeah well I had in preparation I had
seen that he mostly played Kings Indian
setups I I went for d4 and Jung was yeah
I wasn't really expecting what he did he
played and played the bank oh yeah okay
we got a bank oh and against this I am
yeah I mostly played two lines I play
Knight f3 which I did in the game or I
take it and play this long main line
with a format move 12 or 13 it's a bit
long to to show but Nydia 3 is my usual
choice especially if I am didn't do any
special preparation so this is what I
have played I was basically surprised by
the by the bank oh here
and now he even did something something
more problematic hip now played a6 and
transposed to the to the Blumenthal
gambit which I really yeah as sometimes
played it as blacken in blitz games if
you watched my channel recently because
it's it's a fun opening in blitz for
black because you just have those kind
of active possibilities but it's not
like I know anything about the opening
is just yeah playing by ear and now I
had to face this is right yeah I
basically have no idea what to do so I
try to remember something he has
something offbeat that I could do and
well what I didn't want to do it all is
to accept the game but I mean this this
type of this type of play or maybe a six
first I don't know um without any
special prep I don't want to give give
the lower rated opponent this much
activity so when Bishop g5 is the
natural choice but this is also an align
where black has a wide range of
possibilities he can take on d5 play h6
before so I thought for a moment and
then I played Bishop to f4 the only
thing that I remembered is that this had
been recommended in this repertoire book
by Larry Kaufman while ago and I thought
well maybe gives us a try I only know
knew that this is a move that exists but
I have no idea about the details um I
did calculate a bit trying to work out
things over the board and before I
played this of course and yeah what I
came up with is this as being the being
the critical line and it seems to be the
case that this is a principled decision
take stakes and Bishop b7 the Queen a5
has also moved but Bishop d7 attacking
the d5 pawn and here in my um
in my thoughts I mean nothing was
prepared here and I thought that maybe
e4 would be an interesting alternative
intending to play Knight e4 Bishop d3
just playing for quick development this
only has one drawback and this is a move
that I had not seen Bishop d6 I only
found this later when I analyzed the
game it's not a big problem instead of E
for a white also has to move d6 which
also thought about during the game just
blocking the f8 bishop and this leads to
a really an uncommon position yeah this
is what I expected actually but he
played something different he played
Bishop d7 this is very uncommon move but
it does not seem to be to be really bad
yeah here White has again some options
Knight c3 seemed to be the most natural
move to me so I played this yeah and
here it's pretty clear that white is
threatening to take now on b5 with the
night so black must do something
something direct to him it's clear that
B takes c4 is bad due to e4 I think this
can be quickly discarded White will get
the c4 pawn easily and just has a nice
position in the center the b7 bishop is
just biting on this pawn not being very
active so this can be quickly discarded
um I also thought that B form was bad
due to night b5 and I think I was right
in just judgment however after night a6
I didn't see the best move that the
computer points out and this is Queen d3
intending a quickie form what I thought
was that maybe g3 Oh III are decent
moves there's also always this 96 idea
but it needs to be timed correctly if I
do a 96 here this is not leading to much
after Queen b6 and now I need to get
away from this diagonal and
I haven't gained anything so good good
moves our queen d3 and g3 this is
however not what he played he played he
takes d5 and this is a bit risky it
seems to be ok but it it's a bit risky
yeah
ok night XB v this was the idea all
along non-threatening one c7 and maybe
have 96 the right moment I think here in
this position
um he's he's committing a mistake and of
course this is a very early crisis in
the game needs to be very precise he
played they moved d6 basically
overlooking my reply at a leaf what
black should do is to play Knight a6 and
this seems to be quite quite
satisfactory for black for example um
move like 96 is is even bad yeah black
gains a tempo it has Queen a5 coming
it's very very annoying thing to happen
so why shouldn't I shouldn't give the
check my intention in the game was just
to play e3 here and this seems to be ok
III Bishop e7
yeah and now my thought was Knight c3 it
seemed the computer points out a
different setup which is maybe better
but it's a bit yeah a bit
counterintuitive I would say I was
thinking this is what the computer wants
to do and now Bishop to e5 castles 96
with with a slight advantage this is
probably true but it white is not very
well developed I would would have been
very reluctant to do that my idea was to
just drop back and yeah attacking d5 so
we would get this this type of position
where quite surprisingly we reached some
sort of hanging poor information after
he will play d5 and there thought with
95 per share be to f3 White has
very slight pool but it's nothing
nothing particularly threatening for
black this is what he should have done
he played d6 however and yeah yeah at
first I thought that Queen a4 would have
been would have been excellent but this
is in fact not the case the problem is
after Bishop c6 CD 5 this is the point
95 and Queenie for yeah at first you
think okay isn't right almost winning
here what does blacks reply but he has
got 97 and the bishop p on c6 is now
protected it is all on b7 and funny
enough white has no a continuation here
this is losing a piece so you need to
move the Queen again after 95 there's
even a funny repetition possible yeah
this leads to nothing
Queenie 4 and but I also have this move
and this is what I played this is in
fact a very very annoying move for black
not because 96 is an idea it is but the
maid problem is simply this check on e3
yet quite uncommon motif but this check
is a big problem as he cannot easily
interpose a piece on the ephah and the
worst now happened in the game he he
absolutely must play Bishop c6 now
that's the only move that yeah you can
you can still try to play yeah Queen a
white is better but it's not it's not
flat out windy three check and King this
Evan it looks horrible I know but it's
not it's not a flat out when it seems
white is better but not not winning yeah
for example a move like g3 comes to mind
with Bishop h3 threatened yeah and then
black has this check check and this way
gains some counter play there are many
interesting possibilities he instead of
g3 white can also try this this director
move Knight g5 it is not clear to me
however that this leads to to that much
like him maybe take play here it's this
is still very murky the problem was he
took here and after now queen III the
problem is that yeah this is basically a
loss of tempo this dis captured and what
to see is supposed to do now after this
check
yeah Bishop d7 is led out using after
ninety six in fact you should still
continue for a moment as Queen b6 is
trapping the knight it has no no where
to go but after most like Queen III also
g3 probably the strongest why this is
much better if you look at this g3 take
CM Bishop g2 and just castles this is
just a deadly attack white white is not
even material down B just attacks the
King and black is totally uncoordinated
so this is not not really playable
Knight e4 is is also giving away
material in the long run 92 is the
easiest solution at least this is what I
saw in the game long castles is probably
also strong but this is just good enough
Queen here now no long castles is a
strong move
you know f5 night c3 and now you will
win the material here or if black takes
this there is 94 yeah now this threatens
a ton of discoveries yeah and this of
course gives away the rook at least so
on white is completely winning yeah it
cannot really put something on e4 and
there should be seven also note on this
is yeah he needs to play king d7 as ugly
as it looks this happened and now just
lone castles is strong and and simple d6
is hanging by three pieces so he needed
to block that 95 yeah here white has has
two strong moves I played the
simpler one I guess I was also
calculating 95 and it seems that this
with the threat rook takes d5 Queen f5 e
for all kinds of threats it seems to win
as well but at the end I decided to just
play Queenie for this is just easier
Luke takes d5 is the threat he cannot
move the night as b7 is hanging and I
also have Queen f5 check as a threat
yeah he decided to play Queen f6 but we
are already yeah
already he's already beyond saving Queen
b6 is a move that also could could be
checked but white is more than one good
reply
it seems the the strongest is or the
most forceful there's probably night x
d6 um I actually thought about my queen
f5 in the game 96 seems to be the
quickest but this was my my idea in the
game Queen f5 check King needs to move
that's the problem here King e8 and now
Knight g5 and this seems to be seems to
be decisive
yeah let's say Queen takes jacks here
and now the the easiest is to just take
on d5 and yeah like this black is beyond
saving Bishop takes Queen take this as
this one hanging knight f7 and and it's
just is just far too much to defend um
you know as as mentioned the computer
wants to to take here which also is very
strong I didn't consider this so much in
the game but it's very very strong as
well if we look at this 96 what's now
Jack Bishop e6 Bishop d6 no sorry not 56
rook t5 of course sorry yeah I'm up to
550 525 this is also a very strong as 95
as
yeah there are multiple ways but well
this is what he played I took on d5 yeah
I now I'm well he captured him what what
else is there
I'm just threatening too much him yeah
he took I'm recaptured
yeah and now one important point is of
course that if like he takes he I just
have a three protecting the Queen and
still threatening to take the rook
there's also Queen b7 it's also an
important check yeah he played played
knight c6 trying to hang on but it's
already an beyond repair yeah g3 is a
strong move not true not difficult to
find but still good bishop h3 this is
the next threat and here you went Queen
e6 yeah here I calculated a bit Bishop
age 3
it is winning but then I decided to just
keep it simple can show you the line
Bishop 83 it looks quite quite fancy so
I calculated it to this and now Bishop
d6 yeah with all these discovered moves
it is it is a complete win but what I
did is just according to the keep it
simple rule play 95 this is just the
easiest heap he must take with the night
what else is there and now Queen g7
that's important first gives a check so
that you can pick up the rook with a
check again King drop back Janus check
yeah and now I'm yeah marry there is you
played Queen c8 but there is nothing
else he can go here but then just 97
wins easily with the knight coming to d5
why does the piece up it's not just the
mating attack that's decisive but also
peace yeah played Queen c8 well here
thought a moment can I meet him but it's
just useless to to spend any time on
that I just took on c8 and after that he
resigned after after King takes for
example this kind of line leaves wide
with an with an extra night here and
ya know no play whatsoever for the peace
cells he resigned the game here very
very quick win in the second round I was
very very delighted to to have a clear
win and and a quick win to just save
some yeah to just save some energy for
the upcoming rounds it was already the
second game of the day and I'm very
welcome
quick win yeah this sometimes can happen
in those very oopss was a bit too much
in those very sharp openings as the
Blumenthal you can easily yeah make a
misstep and then quickly loses the game
yeah Bishop f4 was a bit term was a bit
of a surprise for him I guess we also
talked too often briefly after the game
and it seems that he mostly concentrated
his preparation on Knight f3 which I
mostly play but d4 I didn't really
consider so okay yeah very nice quick
win and with two out of two I was
guaranteed to get a really really good
opponent and in the next round as in
this type of tournament 2 out of 2 is
it's not scored that often so you're
pretty much guaranteed to get one of the
one of the big guys so yeah this will be
the subject of the third video to be
released tomorrow where I will have my
first grandmaster opponent in this
tournament thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed it